- [Male Dog] Okay you
want me to be honest?
I just don't think two dogs
would share spaghetti like that.
(upbeat whistling music)
- [Lucy] Hi there, I'm Lucy.
- [Gus] I'm Gus.
- [Oliver] Your name.
What, oh, I'm Oliver.
- [Fiona] I'm Fiona.
- [Lucy] And today we're gonna be watching
famous movie dogs.
Oh, that's Dug from Up.
I love this movie.
- [Dug] My name is Dug
and I have just met you
and I love you.
- [Lucy] Aw, I love old people.
But you have to be really
careful not to knock them over.
- [Dug] He made me this
collar, so that I may talk.
Squirrel!
- [Oliver] Squirrel?
- [Lucy] Squirrel, oh my god.
- [Oliver] Did someone say squirrel?
- [Lucy] I love Squirrels.
- [Girl Dog] Very accurate portrayal
of squirlatus insanos,
AKA obsessed with squirrels.
Oh, Lady and the Tramp, where do I start?
I don't mean to be the bad dog but
this scene it's just,
it's a little pretentious,
And she doesn't even touch the meatball.
- [Oliver] Whoa, there's music in this!
Why is that human squeezing
two shoe boxes together.
Can I have some spaghetti?
- [Male Dog] This is so romantic.
I would totally go on this date.
Except replace the other dog
with a second bowl of spaghetti.
Oh, Marley and Me, get the tissues out.
I just peed on the rug,
someone needs to clean that up.
Aw so real, dogs love food, is that good?
Okay, now can we put on
the cat fails compilation?
- [Lucy] Is he in trouble?
I love getting in trouble,
but I also love being a good dog.
This movie is so confusing.
- [Girl Dog] Oh, Isle of Dogs,
I really enjoyed this one.
- Wait a second,
before we attack each other
and tear ourselves to shreds
like a pack of maniacs.
- [Girl Dog] Gorgeous hair
and makeup in this movie.
Is that, I'm just realizing
this now as I listen,
is that Ed Norton?
- She see's the future.
- Huh, no.
She understands TV.
- [Lucy] Oh, sorry, am
I not allowed up here?
I also just need to say
that everyone in this room
is my best friend.
- [Courtney] Outbreak of snout fever
rips through the city of Megasaki.
- [Oliver] No, I am listening,
there's just a pretzel
stuck under the keys here
and I can see it.
If someone could help me, just, please.
- [Male Dog] Okay, where's the dog?
Aren't we watching dog movies?
I'm getting bored.
If we don't go for a walk soon I'm gonna--
(mimics dog shaking off)
- [Oliver] Super realistic
slobber in this scene.
I can not stop looking
at this light over here,
it feels like I can't look away.
Help, help, help.
- [Lucy] This makes me
wanna chase something.
This shirt is so itchy.
Would anyone in here
mind running away from me
so I can chase them?
- [Girl Dog] Yeah, yeah.
I mean, I guess this is realistic.
I'm sorry, this video
just feels super strange.
I think you guys are running out of ideas.
- [Male Dog] That's it?
We're done?
Okay good, because I have
to go to the bathroom,
and this time it's number two.
(upbeat whistling music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel,
and now you're part.
- [Together] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.